si on devait ajouter les patients qui
souffrent d'alzheimer à la liste de ceux
qui pourraient réclamer le droit légal
de mourir
les intentions de ces personnes
devraient être sans équivoque
c'est la première pierre que vient
déposer à l'édifice de nouveaux débats
sur la question
la députée du parti québécois véronique
hivon oui on en parlait déjà
d'ailleurs il ya une recommandation de
notre rapport de deux commissions
spécifiquement là dessus a besoin qu'on
souhaite que la question soit approfondi
par un comité d'experts présidé par le
collège des médecins
il faut éviter ce noël les dérivés
assuré que la demande vient de la
personne elle-même et non de ses proches
une opinion qui a du poids car véronique
hivon et celle qui est à l'origine des
premières démarches sur le précédent
gouvernement du parti québécois visant à
doter le québec d'une loi légalisant
l'aide médicale à mourir parce qu'on
avait fait un mois qu'on n'était pas
assez bien outillés sur la question
spécifique des gens atteints de maladies
dégénératives du cerveau par confins que
c'est une question qui préoccupe
beaucoup la population et je pense que
ce serait un point de départ pour des
vols pendant que véronique hivon
réclament la tenue donc d'une commission
parlementaire
notre député celui-là du parti de
l'action démocratique du québec se sent
interpellé personnellement sa mère
souffre de la maladie dans un mur à un
stade avancé
ma mère ne sauvera pas taillé pop sauf
que si elle s'était vue je l'avais dit
maman dans 20 ans je risque d'être comme
ça je suis ton seul fils aujourd'hui mon
frère est parti
qu'est ce que je fais si tu ressembles à
100 françois bonnardel réclame donc lui
aussi que le débat se fasse entre
parlementaires sur cette question
délicate puis surtout les cinq six
dernières années
ma mère ne parle plus ne marche plus
elle ne me reconnais plus ne sourit plus
et quand la loi sur les médicale à
mourir a été votée je me disais on
oublié on oublie près de 140 mille
personnes qui sont atteintes de cette
maladie d'une des membres de maladies
cognitives
parce qu'on est la deuxième nation la
plus vieillissante après le japon on
aura peut-être cent mille cent cinquante
mille autres personnes qui seront
atteints de cette maladie
les dix prochaines années c'est une
feuille de vigne on est maman répand
soins palliatifs mais c'est presque
pareil c'est un soin palliatif qui dure
depuis des années mais élargir la loi
une nouvelle catégorie de patients
pourraient créer à court terme un
problème logistique important selon les
médecins qui s'occupent de la question
plusieurs prévoyaient par exemple en
décembre 2015 qu'une cinquantaine de
malades par année tout au plus aurait
recours à l'aide médicale à mourir
or il serait en ce moment environ 250 à
faire la demande
il y a peu de médecins qui acceptent les
demandes d'aidé médicale à mourir et le
nombre de demandes d médical
augmenterait de mois en mois ça permet à
tout le monde d'être là d'être présent
au moment du décès ça permet à tout le
monde de faire des derniers adieux ou
désirent une dernière fois ce qu'on peut
être on n'a pas pu dire de vivre ce
moment alors en famille alain nault et
médecins un des rares au québec à se
spécialiser dans la demie dit qu'elle à
mourir on a vu les croyais un trait
presqu'un qui ont demandé à recourir à
l'aide médicale à mourir on a des gens
qui désirent rencontrer lemonnier la
journée même où la journée précédente
on est vraiment dans l'essence même de
l'être humain là qui est dans ces
derniers jours de vie et qui nous fait
une demande qui nous demande de mettre
la science et notre humanité à son
service pour mettre fin à des
souffrances
en plus des embûches au sein du corps
médical il y à la résistance des
religieux toujours un facteur dans le
québec de 2010 est la plus récente
trouvant est par exemple est un document
signé par six évêques de l'ouest
canadien qui invitait il ya quelques
temps leurs collègues leurs amis à
refuser les funérailles religieuses aux
croyants qui font appel à l'aide
médicale à mourir
une affaire qui a suscité de vives
réactions au québec
l'archevêque de valleyfield au québec
noël simard au lieu commence à dire vous
dites oui on me dit non à cela d'abord
commencé par être un contact avec la
famille et
marcher avec eux essayer de comprendre
leur demain qu'est ce que ce qu'est ce
qu'ils veulent recevoir
qu'est ce que ça signifie pour eux et
ensuite on accompagne lyon voix et avec
eux on discerne je pense donc souvent
les gens ne réalisent pas toutes les
conséquences des gestes c'est sûr aussi
que la personne qui ait fait ce choix
est ce qu'elle la tête un véritable
connaissance de cause
mais cette personne bien sûr à leurs
besoins que
en plus celui tier même si elle est
décédée une parole commando miséricorde
et c'est ce que la famille veut entendre
parce que très souvent un le geste de 2k
nazis et affecte beaucoup la famille
dans ce débat c'étaient les patients qui
ont eu le premier mot et maintenant
c'est peut-être aussi que devrait
revenir le dernier mot l'essentiel est
dit ici en quelques mots dans cette
entrevue exclusive en 2016 de michel
berreur avec jean brault 48 heures avant
d'obtenir la médicale à mourir
massin détendu comme c'est pour la
première fois depuis très très longtemps
quelqu'un m'a 21 ma main tendue qui
comprenait des situations ce que vous
n'avez pas non
quinte avec une vie qui en amène la
pince existent eux c'est pas l'or comme
la personne normale que de coin perdent
moins cher y est vous avez rien à perdre
vous l'impression qu'au contraire les
gagne oui c'est une image parfait fois
témoigne d'une seconde b un reportage de
radio canada international